gegen abend und willkommen zu heute live
ja in einer knappen halben stunde
beginnt das wm-qualifikationsspiel der
deutschen fußball-nationalmannschaft
gegen nord mazedonien und dabei geht es
um die teilnahme an einem turnier
nämlich der wm in katar 2022 das äußerst
umstritten ist und das schon seit vielen
jahren vor allem aufgrund der
menschenrechtssituation im
austragungsland katar durch aktionen und
äußerungen der dfb spieler in den
letzten tagen ist diese problematik
erneut stark in den fokus gerückt aber
wie schlimm ist die situation für die
arbeiter in katar genau in welche
vorteile bringt es für das land und die
menschen dort dass das land die wm
austragen darf darauf wollen wir schauen
und darüber wollen wir diskutieren mit
unseren gesprächspartnern heute abend
unter anderem andreas rettig er ist
prominenter fußballfunktionär unter
anderem als manager in freiburg köln und
st pauli tätig gewesen
aber auch zwei jahre lang
geschäftsführer der deutschen fußball
liga dfl
und er sagt die wm-vergabe nach katar
war ein großer fehler und die
fußball-bosse gehen über leichen nicht
alles an der wm-vergabe nach katar ist
schlecht hält sylvia schenk dagegen sie
ist menschenrechtsexperten bei der anti
korruptions organisation transparency
international
und sie sagt einen boykott des turniers
wie zuletzt wieder öfter gefordert wäre
völlig verkehrt in bayern erst mal einen
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen hier in unserem live stream
schön dass sie dabei sind
rettig bevor wir zum thema kommen mal
ganz vor weg gefragt freuen sie sich
eigentlich gleich auf das spiel der
deutschen mannschaft ist heute ein spiel
qualität
ja also es rauscht ein wenig an einem
vorbei in diesen tagen und ich muss
ehrlich sagen ich hab eben erst
realisiert gegen wenig deutsche
mannschaft tatsächlich heute abend
spielt verstehe also hat momentan nicht
die top priorität
sie sind heute mit einem interview in
der hamburger morgenpost zu lesen in dem
sie sieben thesen formulieren warum sie
gegen die wm in katar sind was stört sie
dann am meisten
ja die vergabe insgesamt ich meinem land
die wm zu geben die schon beim damaligen
zeitpunkt der größte die größten co2
ausstoß hatte pro kopf gesehen der
nichts dafür tut was das thema der
menschenrechte angeht
der bisher wie gesagt nicht aufgefallen
ist in verschiedener hinsicht hier was
das thema menschenrechte im allgemeinen
angeht einem solchen staat die wm zu
geben da muss ich ehrlich gestehen im
kenntnis noch der rahmenbedingungen des
klimas rücksichtnahme auf sportler im
sommer wären ja glaub über 40 grad im
schnitt gewesen
dafür hört schon viel fantasie dazu den
etwas positives abzugewinnen
das war jetzt schon einige punkte die
wir gleich noch mal der reihe nach auf
durchgehend wollen frau schenkt sie
haben heute wiederum dem spiegel ein
interview gegeben in dem sie die
wm-vergabe oder indem sie dieser
durchaus auch positive seiten abgewinnen
können was hat sie bewogen dieses
interview zu geben
ich bin gefragt worden nein also der
hintergrund ist ja man muss deutlich
unterscheiden zwischen der
vergabeentscheidung im dezember 2010 und
allem was seitdem passiert ist die
vergabeentscheidung hatte ganz ganz
viele schwächen einige hat der herr
rettig eben aufgezählt die klimatischen
verhältnisse vor allen dingen aber auch
weil die fifa kein menschenrechts
konzept verlangt hat von katar und den
anderen bewerbern gilt übrigens auch für
die gleichzeitige vergabe nach russland
für den fifa world cup 2018 die
menschenrechtsprobleme in russland sind
mindestens so groß wie in katar das kann
man durchaus sagen also insofern die
vergabe ist das eine aber nachdem die
vergabe passiert war hat sicher eine
ganze menge getan und ich hoffe dass wir
das jetzt gleich noch im detail
diskutieren und es hat sich und das
stimmt nicht was der herr rettig sagt
die machen gar nichts für die
menschenrechte in katar es hat sich
genau da sehr viel bewegt deshalb bin
ich mir einig mit jungen rights watch
amnesty international und den
internationalen gewerkschaften dass kein
boykott passieren darf sondern dass das
was sich entwickelt hat und weiter
entwickelt in katar unterstützt werden
muss durch die durchführung der
weltmeisterschaft wunderbar da haben wir
schon mal zwei kontroverse standpunkte
gleich zu beginn bei ihnen beiden
abgeholt bevor wir weiter in die
diskussion einsteigen wollen wir aber
alle für für alle zuschauer
beziehungsweise user nochmal darstellen
dies vielleicht auch nicht so mit sport
im allgemeinen oder fußball im
besonderen haben was es mit dieser wm in
katar auf sich hat warum diese so
kontrovers diskutiert wird und mein
kollege jonas potash hat dazu ein paar
einzelheiten die fußball-wm 2022 hat
kein gutes image bereits die vergabe des
turniers nach katar wird von
korruptionsvorwürfen überschattet später
wird es nicht besser international
hagelt es kritik an den
arbeitsbedingungen auf qatars vielen wm
baustellen
es wird von zahlreichen todesfällen
unter arbeitern berichtet diese kommen
in der regel aus ländern wie indien
nepal und china in das emirat
der katarische wm organisator weist die
vorwürfe zurück
[Musik]
einige leute haben eine schmierkampagne
gegen mein land organisiert aber wir
haben bewiesen dass unsere wm für
positiven wandel steht und dass alle
anschuldigungen falsch sind
wir gehen unseren weg tatsächlich hat
kat us regierung schritte unternommen um
die situation der arbeiter zu verbessern
doch deutliche veränderungen seien
ausgeblieben kritisieren die
menschenrechtsorganisation human rights
watch und amnesty international
dabei geht es vor allem um das
sogenannte cover system arbeitsmigranten
bekommen ihr visum nur für eine stelle
bei einem konkreten arbeitgeber diese
bekommen so viel macht über ihre
mitarbeiter eine folge viele arbeiter
bekommen ihren lohn zu spät nur
teilweise oder gar nicht
in deutschland regt sich immer mehr
kritik an der wm vor dem
qualifikationsspiel gegen island trug
die nationalmannschaft trikots mit der
aufschrift human rights menschenrechte
auch nationalspieler toni kroos geht mit
dem wm gastgeber katar hart ins gericht
ich finde die vergabe an katar nicht gut
das eine sind die arbeitsbedingungen das
andere dass homosexualität dort unter
strafe steht und verfolgt wird
das sind punkte die absolut inakzeptabel
sind für einen boykott der wm spricht
sich gross jedoch nicht aus er denke
nicht dass sich dadurch die
arbeitsbedingungen verändern würden
teamkollege kazuki mich sieht das
ähnlich generell bin ich der meinung
dass für einen boykott zehn jahre zu
spät dran sind zehn jahre zu spät dran
für einen boykott sagte rosberg ich
hätte ich ganz konkret gefragt wie sehen
sie das wären sie für einen boykott
seitens der deutschen mannschaft ich
denke dass ich in der tat schwierig ich
wollte nur noch eine anmerkung machen
was das die ausführung von frau schenk
angeht weil es wird ja tatsächlich ist
mag sein dass es verbesserungen gibt es
ist ein schwer vorstellbar frauchen weil
in dem land wo es keine unabhängige
medien gibt keine interviews keine
gewerkschaften ist es natürlich schwer
an valide verlässliche und belastbare
informationen und zahlen zu kommen
dass das eine das zweite ist es wird
sich zwar berühmt und dass das kv system
abgeschafft wurde aber wenn ich den
ausführungen ihrer kollegin der frau
später als katar experte bei amnesty
glauben schenken darf die haben nicht
vor allzu langer zeit noch gesagt dass
das kraftfahrer system noch existiert
das heißt jetzt nur noch nicht mehr
existiere ist jetzt anders
dann sind das dinge die ja schon
nachdenklich stimmen
und auf der anderen seite ist für mich
immer die frage welchen maßstab lege ich
an ja natürlich können wir nicht direkt
vielleicht den europäischen maßstab
anlegen
aber wir sollten auch nicht im maßstab
von saudi arabien und den vereinigten
arabischen emiraten anlegen frau schenkt
sie können direkt endgegnern aber
vielleicht waren sie noch mal die frage
sie haben sich explizit gegen einen
boykott ausgesprochen warum wäre ein
boykott unter vielleicht auch
einbeziehung der sache ärgert sich
gerade gesagt hat keine gute idee aus
ihrer sicht
also wenn sie genau zuhören was auch die
regina spettel von amnesty sagt dass
auch das stets cogburn der
europabeauftragte von amnesty mit dem
ich seit jahren zusammenarbeite in den
letzten wochen gesagt hat dann sagen sie
es hat fortschritte gegeben
die sind auch nicht china sondern da hat
sich wirklich was bewegt das bestreitet
niemand auch nicht um rights watch nicht
die internationalen gewerkschaften aber
natürlich gibt es wir übrigens auch in
deutschland dann immer noch fälle und in
katar auch noch ein paar mehr als in
deutschland leider wo es noch nicht
funktioniert weil die umsetzung zeit
braucht aber das entscheidende ist doch
befördern wir jetzt die weitere
umsetzung oder wird diese entwicklung
gestoppt und wie geht es denn außerhalb
der betroffenen bauarbeitern muss ich
wirklich erhebliches verbessert hat das
hat übrigens auch regina sporteln nicht
bestritten sondern wie sieht es in
anderen branchen aus im moment geht es
darum das was sich in bewegung gesetzt
hat und was auch tatsächlich passiert
ich habe dieses diese woche noch mit
einem vertreter der internationalen
gewerkschaften der sich circa zehn jahre
um katar intensiv gekümmert hat
gesprochen hat es mir schriftlich noch
einmal bestätigt die reformen sind real
und es ist sehr viel umgesetzt
es ist ein entwicklungsprozess
angestoßen so hat er gesagt der nach
seiner kenntnis noch kein land in der
geschichte so schnell gemacht hat wie es
katar gemacht hat und es ist einfach
nicht richtig dass es keine
gewerkschaften vor ort gibt die
gewerkschaften haben erstmals auf
internationaler ebene mit katar 2016
einen vertrag geschlossen
seitdem ist die internationale
gewerkschaft vor ort mit
baustellenbesichtigung mit
verbesserungsvorschlägen usw
das wird stück für stück abgearbeitet
und die internationale labour
organisation die für die vereinten
nationen un für alle staaten
entsprechende maßnahmen umsetzt ist auch
seit drei jahren vor ort und es hat
erhebliche verbesserung gegeben das hat
mir der generalsekretär der
internationalen labour organisation auch
gestern noch mal per e mail bestätigt
also insofern es hat sich ganz viel
getan aber worum es jetzt geht in
anderen branchen in den hotels im
transport bei den hausangestellten
insbesondere weil die hausangestellten
isoliert den einzelnen haushalten sind
da kommt man an die arbeitgeber auch mit
kontrollen und mit vorgaben
wie sieht es denn aus werden die reform
dort umgesetzt halt nicht so leicht ran
es ist viel einfacher mit baufirmen dann
entsprechend wo hunderte oder sogar
tausende arbeiter sind kontrollen
durchzuführen und die dinge
festzustellen
also die hausangestellten sind im moment
ein problem das hat die regina spöttl
deutlich angesprochen unterstütze ich
und die internationale solidarität mit
den migranten arbeiterinnen und
arbeitern in katar die muss weitergehen
und deshalb kann es keinen boykott geben
und im übrigen saudi arabien ist viel
viel katastrophaler da wären dann wäre
es gut gewesen wenn die profis vom fc
bayern münchen nicht mit nach riad
geflogen werden zum spiel kurz nachdem
der coach auch schon in der botschaft
hinter spengler aus das römerlager den
fc bayern münchen das kommt später aber
ich würde gerne nochmal beim thema katar
bleiben
sie hatten jetzt angesprochen die
entwicklung der gewerkschaften die
offensichtlich unterschiedlich beurteilt
wird hier von ihnen beiden aber was mir
auch aufgefallen ist bei der lektüre
ihre interviews sie beide ordnern die
zahl der toten arbeiter die ist ja
verstorbenen arbeitet dies ja nun auch
gegeben hat laut einem bericht der
zeitung guardian sind es in zehn jahren
immerhin 6509 sie ordnen das sehr
unterschiedlich ein vielleicht frau
schenkt sie zuerst was bedeuten diese
zahlen für sie oder was machen sie da
raus also der guardian hat vor einem
jahr berichtet dass es seit dem beginn
der bauarbeiten für die wm auf den wm
baustellen 34 tote und todesfälle durch
unfälle von bauarbeitern gegeben hat er
hat dieses jahr berichtet dass von 1,4
millionen migranten arbeitern die gar
nicht alle bauarbeiter center sind auch
wir sind migranten arbeiterinnen dabei
hausangestellte taxifahrer it-experten
aus indien und so weiter das von 1,4
millionen menschen aus fünf asiatischen
ländern die in qatar leben diese 6500
todesfälle vorgekommen sind
diese zahl sagt überhaupt nichts aus
solange man nicht weiß woran sind die
gestorben
wie alt waren die menschen waren es
männer oder frauen wir haben auch in
deutschland todesraten die bei einer
josi werden sie in bestreiten dass die
arbeitsbedingungen in katar nicht
unbedingt gesundheitsfördernd waren
so wie wir das jetzt in den letzten
jahren ja immer wieder auch gehört haben
das ist ja also die arbeitsbedingungen
zur zeit der völker habe 2010 waren in
ganz ganz vielen fällen katastrophal
insbesondere auf den baustellen sie
haben sich auf den baustellen und
insbesondere auf den direkten wm
baustellen das sind für mich übrigens
nicht nur die stadien
das ist auch die dazugehörige
infrastruktur auf das metro ist oder
zufahrt oder sonst was
da haben sie sich erheblich verbessert
das sagen ihnen die deutschen
gewerkschaften
fragen sie die ig bau nach da waren
deutscher experte der vize vorsitzende
der ig bau agrar umwelt der dietmar
schäfers war mehrfach in katar hat dass
dort alles mit inspiziert und betreut
das sagen sagt die internationale bau
gewerkschaft das sagt der internationale
gewerkschaftsbund ich weiß nicht woher
rettig seine informationen her bekommt
ich arbeite seit mindestens sechs jahren
mit diesen menschen zusammen ich arbeite
mit weiteren menschenrechtsexperten
zusammen im unabhängigen beirat der
fleischer für menschenrechte habe ich
mit der ratsche day ja der punkt ist
angekommen vielen dank bis hierhin aber
ich würde jetzt dann tatsächlich auch
ein rette ich noch mal zu wort kommen
lassen also das argument mit dem
mehreren tausend toten arbeitern ist
dass am ende eine überdramatisierung
oder wie sehen sie das
ja ich kann es natürlich genauso wenig
beurteilen in der tiefe wie verschenkt
weil eben tatsächlich keine belastbaren
zahlen vorliegen ich habe eben ihr schon
mal gesagt sind keine unabhängigen
medien vor ort
das ist wie wenn sie in china zahlen
geliefert bekommen dann sind die auch
mit vorsicht zu genießen deswegen ist
das ein bisschen schwierig vor allen
dingen aber es sind ja nun die zahlen
die bekannt sind dass das sprechen über
30 bis 40 tausend die an dem bau
beteiligt sind und wenn man das
verhältnis selbst was die todesfälle
angeht dann wird das feld ist natürlich
ein deutlich schwierigeres in der
beurteilung und was mich am meisten
stört ist in der tat dass man jetzt den
eindruck bekommt verschenkt als wenn
hier mit riesenschritten einem
vorzeigestaat präsentiert wird und das
muss ich sagen
mich dann schon gewaltig es mag sein
dass es punktuelle verbesserungen gibt
das ist alles in ordnung aber dem grunde
nach sind wir uns doch hoffentlich einig
dass diese wm niemals hätte nach katar
vergeben werden dürfen und dass die
anstrengungen jetzt gemacht werden sind
und der druck der ausgeübt wird von
politische lobby von unternehmen viel zu
wenig ist wenn ich sehe welche
abhängigkeitsverhältnisse hier sind von
der deutschen bank über vw über den fc
bayern wie auch immer wer alles hier
paktiert mit geldern aus doha oder wo
auch immer herkommen
dann ist doch das grundproblem aus
meiner sicht dass wir jetzt untersuchen
ein wenig reinzuwaschen indem er
aktionen machen oder in dem normalen
spendenaktionen machen aber wir sollten
eher mal die frage stellen wie werden
diese gewinne erwirtschaftet die dort
dann dazu führen dass man sechs
verteilen kann also nicht stört die
gesamte positive beurteilung des staates
katar haben also ich halte noch mal ganz
kurz fest es gibt alle ja ganz kurz vor
schenk ich würde noch mal ganz kurz ein
zwischenfazit ziehen
also sie sind sich einig darüber dass es
eine positive entwicklung gibt über die
qualität beziehungsweise das ausmaß
dieser entwicklung herrscht dissens frau
schenk herr rettig sinn überhaupt keine
einzige quelle haben sie den guardian
artikel gelesen
dort steht nicht drin dass es 6500 tote
bauarbeiter sind der guardian artikel
ist seit seinem ersten erscheinen
ich glaube dreiundzwanzigster februar
inzwischen drei mal nachgebessert worden
weil sie anscheinend selber erschrocken
sind wie dieser artikel interpretiert
worden ist also bitte lesen sie das
sagen sie mit wem sie gesprochen haben
die internationalen gewerkschaften sind
vor ort in katar
die haben mir das ja direkt berichtet
und warum soll ich denen nicht glauben
sie die arbeiten seit jahren daran
und warum soll ich den gewerkschaften
auch den erfolg nicht gönnen also da hat
sich eine menge bewegt die haben nicht
den fuß in der tür sondern das ganze
bein in der tür in der golfregion die
hoffen jetzt ständig inständig dass der
druck weiter geht sage ich auch druck
machen damit auch in den anderen golf
ländern saudi arabien den emiraten
bahrain und so weiter etwas in bewegung
gerät
und damit auch das was jetzt in weiten
teilen im bauarbeiter bereich in qatar
sich getan hat auf die hausangestellten
auf hotel transport und so weiter
übertragen wird und natürlich ist es gut
wenn der fc bayern nach katar fährt oder
die deutsche nationalmannschaft dass sie
mit ihren hotelpartnern sprechen und
fragen was macht ihr denn wie behandelt
ihr eure arbeiterinnen und arbeiter
da ist noch eine menge zu tun das
bestreite ich nicht aber bitte sehen
dass ich auch sehr viel in bewegung
gesetzt hat sehr viel getan hat und dass
das auch wichtig ist um zu lernen für
die zukunft und nochmal wir brauchen
jetzt das internationale engagement das
das was erreicht wurde stabilisiert wird
und in andere bereiche ausstrahlt also
frau schenk plädiert sozusagen für einen
wandel durch handel oder durch
annäherung zumindest so kann man es
vielleicht festhalten und sieht darin
durchaus chancen herr rettig ich würde
noch mal auf einen anderen punkt zu
sprechen kommen sie bemängeln außerdem
in ihrem interview beziehungsweise in
ihren thesen das ist die fifa sehr wohl
schaffe eigene steuervorteile in den
austragungsländer durchzusetzen aber das
ist eben nicht in ausreichendem maß
gelingt auf die einhaltung von
menschenrechten zu dringen wie erklären
sie sich diese ja dann doch recht
zynisch prioritätensetzung der fifa ja
das ist ja in der tat nicht mehr
nachvollziehbar warum fifa im übrigen
auch das ioc wenn ich an vergaben denke
wie olympia seinerzeit 2008 nach china
und jetzt wieder die austragung 2022 wo
ja auch menschenrechtsverletzungen nun
bekannt sind und wo es damals schon
nicht möglich war das natürlich auch der
zunge zergehen lassen dass im
internationalen pressezentrum als
beispiel keine freie internet zugänge
für journalisten da waren und wenn ich
jetzt sehe dass es die fifa nicht
schafft hier zwar steuerprivilegien für
das unternehmen fifa heraus zu
verhandeln aber sachen wie
nachhaltigkeit und das zu koppeln eine
vergabe an die einhaltung von
menschenrechten nicht in der lage ist
dann muss ich ehrlich gestehen dann
fehlen mir die worte
frau schenk wie sehen sie das also herrn
rattle fehlen vor allen dingen die
information ist finde ich unglaublich
muss jetzt einfach mal sehr deutlich
werden wie populistisch sie hier jetzt
vorgehen
ohne eine blasse ahnung zu haben ja ich
habe vorhin gesagt die vergabe zu zehn
war ohne menschenrechts konzept ohne
alles aber sie müssen sehen was sich
inzwischen getan hat die fifa hat für
die vergabe für 2026 marokko gegen
united mit usa kanada mexiko intensiv
ein menschenrechts konzept verlangt hat
in unabhängig prüfen lassen wie die
menschenrechtssituation in allen
beteiligten bewerberländern ist die
macht das jetzt auch für die frauen
weltmeisterschaft für u19 und weiß ich
was ist dann auch für veranstaltungen
gibt in allen bereichen sie bindet
vertraglich die ausrichter an
menschenrechts konzepte und an
nachhaltigkeit das ist beispielgebend
ich wäre froh wenn das ioc so etwas
hätte und wenn viele andere
sportverbände dass auch hätten ich
verteidige jetzt nicht infantino und
irgendwelche porsche ganz oben ich
verteidige die die die harte arbeit
machen und es geht nicht um wandel durch
handel oder durch wandel einfach weil
sie dort einmal fußball spielen da ist
über jahre intensiver arbeit gemacht
worden
es genügt ja nicht das kv system durch
gesetz zu verbieten und abzuschaffen
sondern sie brauchen zb inspektoren die
dann auch nachprüfen und kontrollieren
wird das umgesetzt wie wird das
umgesetzt wie sehen die
sicherheitsstandards auf den baustellen
aus ihren regeln und den kolleginnen
gewerkschaften aus
ihre kollegin frau spöttl ist vor zu
ganz anderen ergebnissen gekommen
vor ungefähr 100 noch einen ganz anderen
ergebnissen gekommen
also nach allem was ich von der frau
spöttl jetzt in den letzten wochen und
monaten ich weiß nicht was sie vor acht
monaten gesagt hat gelesen habe hat sie
auch gesagt es hat sich viel getan
es muss verstetigt werden es muss sich
noch mehr tun das sage ich auch ich sage
auch es muss ich noch mehr tun ich finde
es auch gut wenn der internationale
druck weiter geht das bestreite ich ja
nicht aber die frage ist ja ob ich jetzt
alles verdamme in katar oder ob ich sagt
da hat sich was getan es muss jetzt noch
auf andere branchen übertragen werden es
muss in die anderen länder übertragen
werden es muss in katar weiter gehen und
auf dauer mindestens das niveau halten
beziehungsweise noch darüber hinausgehen
das leben einfach macht geleistet wurden
die muss weitergehen
ja weil sie eben einen
defizite aus gestrichen haben ich
beziehe mich hier auf die süddeutsche
zeitung vom 16
juni in des letzten jahres mit einem
wirklich bemerkenswerten interview ihrer
kollegin vielleicht sollten sich das
auch mal anschauen
er hätte ich würde gerne noch mal
wirklich einhalten ist nicht meine
kollegin frau schon ganz kurz und dann
würde ich gern weitergehen
die frau ist nicht meine kollegin das
letzte was ich jetzt in den vergangenen
wochen von ihr gelesen habe war kein
boykott es hat sich was getan
es muss sich noch mehr tun und es geht
insbesondere um die hausangestellten
herr rettig sie stören sich außerdem an
dem system fifa in dem jahr
weltmeisterschaft nachweislich gekauft
würden wie sie sagen ist das nicht
angesichts unserer probleme jetzt in
deutschland die wir haben im
zusammenhang mit der sommermärchen
affäre und auch ungeklärten geldflüssen
nach wie vor ist das nicht eine kritik
die weit über katar hinaus reicht ja
keine frage also ich finde nicht dass
wir hier so selbstbewusst als deutsche
die mit dem finger auf andere zeigen
können auch daher gibt es ja noch
fragezeichen
dass wir haben es gerade richtigerweise
gesagt es steht man sommer märchen und
aber fakt ist es gibt eben halt
international rechtskräftige
verurteilungen vieler fifa-funktionäre
die beteiligt waren an diesen
entscheidungsprozessen und das sind
fakten an denen kann man ja nicht vorbei
frau schenkt also in der morgenpost habe
ich heute gelesen dass der herr rettig
behauptet es sei juristisch nachgewiesen
dass es dort korruption bei der vergabe
nach katar gegeben hat das ist mir nicht
bekannt ich habe alles gelesen in den
letzten zehn elf jahren was man da zu
lesen konnte es hat gerüchte gegeben es
ist nichts nachgewiesen worden
da müssen wir sehr vorsichtig sein die
funktionäre die verurteilt wurden das
waren im wesentlichen südamerikaner die
sich bestechen haben lassen von us
amerikanischen agenturen und tv-rechte
händlern also da muss man wirklich alles
sehr genau an johns hat viel korruption
bei der fifa gegeben es gibt immer noch
korruption im fußball es gibt korruption
in deutschland das wissen wir auch alles
wir müssen an allen fronten kämpfen und
dürfen damit auch nicht nachlassen da
bin ich immer
dabei aber bitteschön schauen wo sich
was bewegt hat und noch mal es geht
darum dass wir im sport die
menschenrechte voranbringen und das geht
nur mit der arbeit mit den un
leitprinzipien für wirtschaft und
menschenrechte
da hat sich im fußball in der fifa in
katar einiges getan diesen prozess
müssen wir fortsetzen und dafür brauchen
wir unterstützung und die internationale
solidarität
ja also auf diesen prozess aufmerksam
machen möchte jedenfalls auch die
deutsche nationalmannschaft wir haben
vorhin in dem beitrag auch noch mal die
einlassungen der spieler groß oder auch
chemisch gehört wir haben noch mal die
bilder gesehen der nationalmannschaft
mit den t-shirts human rights wie wirken
diese aktionen auf sie beide sind die
fahren wir vielleicht mal mit herrn
rettig an sind die glaubwürdig sind die
vor allem auch zielführend
also ich mach das ja immer ein bisschen
auch an den handelnden personen fest und
wenn spieler wie chemische red skull die
nun wirklich der vergangenheit wirklich
positiv aufgefallen sind durch ihr
soziales engagement durch ja auch
zeichen der solidarität in schwierigen
zeiten
dann nehme ich diesen spielern dass ab
und habe da keinen grund zu zweifeln
dass ich auch ehrlich damit
auseinandersetzen was sicherlich nicht
genug war aber ich denke dass wir nicht
noch deutlich dass man hier dass man
hier in der frage eine noch ein video
gedreht was er in richtung vermarktung
abzielte dass man sicherlich unklug ich
habe wie gesagt aber grundsätzlich an
der waren und unter ähnlichen absicht
von den meisten spielern zumindest kein
zweifel ich verschenke sie haben sich im
vorfeld kritisch geäußert was diese
aktionen angeht
vielleicht kannst du das noch mal
ausführen ja also erstmal ist es immer
toll
das haben wir ja in vielen bereichen im
moment wenn sportlerinnen und sportler
sich einsetzen gerade für menschenrechte
für die werte für die der sport ja
eigentlich stehen sollte als kann ich
nur voll unterstützen auch besser spät
als gar nicht ich hätte mir das hatte
ich vorhin schon kurz angesprochen von
den bayern-spielern deutliches zeichen
bereits gewünscht als es nach saudi
arabien ging vor zwei oder drei
oder auch sonst wenn sie jährlich nach
katar fahren dass sie dort vor ort sich
auch dann mal mit migranten arbeiten zum
beispiel zum gespräch treffen und dort
unterstützung zeigen was mich jetzt
gestört hat ist dass der dfb seine
spieler nicht ausführlicher informiert
hat darüber was sich in katar getan hat
denn sonst hätten sie ja mehr auf die
hausangestellten auf transport und
andere bereiche verwiesen als auf die
bauarbeiter und hätten da sagen können
da hat sich was getan denn der
vizepräsident des dfb doktor rainer koch
ist seit 2000 17 im governance committee
der fifa zuständig für die
menschenrechte der hat alle
informationen vorliegen er konnte alles
weiter geben bzw wenn er meint es hätte
sich nichts positiv entwickelt sondern
es wäre katastrophal
ja warum hat er dann nicht seit 2017
schon alarm geschlagen
also deshalb der dfb hat sich hier
blamiert seit zwei jahren hat er ein
fertiges menschenrechts konzept in der
schublade
seine mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
haben super gearbeitet und es wird nicht
verabschiedet weil sich die herren dort
oben immer nur die köpfe einschlagen
das ist das problem ich wollte fragen
welche welche motivation sollten die
dann haben diese informationen
zurückzuhalten also warum wird dann
toleriert dass die mannschaft trotzdem
solche aktion macht weil sie sich nicht
kümmern weil die immer mit ihren
intrigen oder was weiß ich beschäftigt
bin also wir sind von den menschenrechts
organisationen in deutschland schon vor
zwei jahren konsultiert worden wir haben
papiere gesichtet wir haben kommentiert
da waren junge reizwort schon viele
andere dabei wir haben viel zeit
reingesteckt und das ding ist immer noch
nicht verabschiedet also das verstehe
ich überhaupt nicht wie man bei dem
thema überhaupt nicht vorankommen kann
herr rettig vielleicht haben sie auch
einblicke in den dfb sie waren dfl
funktionär das ist natürlich im
momentanen zeiten auch immer ein heikles
thema beim dfb gibt es probleme das
haben wir mitbekommen in den nachrichten
haben sie dazu eine meinung
ich bin ich oft der meinung von frau
schenken im falle kann ich ihre folgen
in der argumentation ich glaube dass der
dfb zu sehr bei einigen funktionären mit
sich selbst zu sehr beschäftigt ist es
macht keinen guten eindruck das ist
keine geschlossene da und wenn man die
kraft und energie mehr in
positionskämpfen des verbandes
verschwendet alles in diesen dingen die
rhader verschenkt gesagt hat dann kommt
das bei uns zurück zur wm fertig also zu
werden 2022 sie vermuten in ihrem
interview dass es bzw auch wiederum in
ihren thesen dass es zu einem grösseren
boykott dieses turniers er nicht kommen
werde trotzdem haben sie sich dafür
ausgesprochen dass die teilnehmenden
mannschaften dort durchaus zeichen
setzen könnten
wie könnte die aussehen ja also da bin
ich tatsächlich auch etwas näher dann in
der argumentation bei den experten die
sagen dass der boykott tatsächlich
schwierig ist und er nicht zum ziel
führt nämlich zu verbesserungen
ich habe ich hab mal laut gedacht und
vielleicht ein bisschen war der wunsch
der vater des gedanken aber wenn man ein
klares bekenntnis ab gibt beispielsweise
wenn alle verbände die teilnehmen eine
regenbogenfahne in ihr depot aufnehmen
oder die farben oder wenn man sich warm
macht mit dem konterfei von george
wright oder wenn ich sage es mal mit
einem augenzwinkern wenn sich die
funktionäre beim abspielen der
nationalhymnen mal hingehen dann ist das
zwar träumerei das gebe ich zu aber das
wäre natürlich zeichen die um die welt
gehen würden
frau schenkt was halten sie davon also
ich habe eingangs wie schon gesagt ich
finde es immer gut wenn sportlerinnen
und sportler sich für die werte im sport
einsetzen und auch den funktionären mal
zeigen wie man haltung zeigt also
insofern ja lgbt homosexuelle situation
ist in katar weiter ein problem insofern
ich bin nachdem toni kroos dankbar dass
er da noch mal weil wir immer nur über
die migranten arbeiter gesprochen haben
aber da auch noch einmal darauf
hingewiesen hat auch da zeichen zu
setzen ist durchaus richtig wichtiger
aber als solche bekenntnisse die
natürlich plakativ sind und gut in den
medien rüberkommen ist es vor ort mit
dem taxifahrer reden mit der kellnerin
reden mit dem zimmermädchen reden das
sind alles migranten arbeiterinnen und
migranten arbeiter hören wo der schuh
drückt gespräche suchen dass man mit den
hotels wurde wo der dfb nächtigt während
der
fifa wm dass sie dort mit dem reden
schauen wie geht es ihren arbeiterinnen
und arbeitern also wirklich vor ort
pieksen und dafür sorgen dass sich in
katar etwas weiter nach vorne bewegt da
muss man was machen und wenn dann noch
bekenntnisse dazu kommen und plakative
aktionen wunderbar aber nur aktion die
helfen nichts noch mal es ist harte
arbeit die menschenrechte weiter
voranzubringen vor letzte frage an sie
beide schauen sie sich die wm dann
nächstes jahr im fernsehen an oder so
ist corinna zu lästern beim public
viewing auf dem weihnachtsmarkt wie gern
sie das handhaben ist im winter also
public viewing mit mit glühwein fände
ich mal ganz spannend ich werde mir
sicher einzelne spiele anschauen aber
nicht alle das habe ich auch bei den
vergangenen weltmeisterschaften nicht
gemacht das schaffe ich zeitlich ganz
herr rettig ich befürchte dass meine
fußballleidenschaft trotz aller
widrigkeiten so groß ist dass ich vor
der glotze sitzen werde ja das werden
sie wahrscheinlich in wenigen minuten
dann auch tun denn das spiel beginnt ja
jetzt gegen nord mazedonien noch
allerletzte frage an sie beide ihr tipp
was glauben sie wie geht's aus
deutschland gewinnt 2 0
jawoll und ich denke ich denke nicht
dass nord mazedonien hoch gewinnen wird
es ist ein vorsichtiger tipp lassen sie
aber jetzt eine wischi waschi aussage
mit einem schwund einem schmunzeln
härtig alles live messengers angekommen
vielen dank für diese sehr lebendige und
kontroverse debatte das thema wird uns
weiter beschäftigen
vielen dank dass sie beide uns zur
verfügung gestanden haben und einen
schönen abend alles gute für sie danke
sehr ihnen auch dankeschön und natürlich
auch ich liebe user vielen dank fürs
zuschauern heute mal ohne kommentare
beziehungsweise fragen wir hoffen ihr
seht uns dass nach beim nächsten live
stream dann wieder gerne wir wünschen
euch einen schönen abend zu eventuell ja
auch viel spaß beim fußball spielt
ansonsten bis demnächst